so let me let me give you an example an
a-list example do you know who has not
appeared in a major movie in over a
decade
uh christopher reeve okay true
i you got me there i was on the superman
all right so
that i can't blame hollywood bias but i
still do
richard gere oh richard gere uh richard
because he spoke out for tibet he took
on china so i actually had a chance to
meet richard geary he came to the senate
and and was speaking out against chinese
oppression and go back and look and
you know he was in a ton of movies as an
officer
and i mean he was an aid list
like you know major star and go go pull
up his list of films in a decade
no major studio will hire him because
he's dared criticize communist china
and it doesn't matter if you're richard
gere you're done you're doing small
independent films because we're
distributing to china and we want to
make a buck
that's very very chinese it kind of
shows it to me too because it is just
about that buck
and you know we we talk a lot on the
show about like
the oppression the systems of the
institutional oppression that the left
is always prattling on about
but the left controls all of those
institutions right the media
hollywood big tech administrative
government all these sorts of things
and so it does seem to me at this point
if even richard gere
can be effectively canceled because he
speaks out against the communist party
of china
you kind of just have to build the
pirate ship don't you you kind of have
to do
exactly what you did look for people
never stop talking about paying your
fair share and blah blah blah
ten years ago i was doing a show in
winnipeg of all places
and it was the middle of the winter and
no one should go to winnipeg in the
middle of winter but anyway
i was getting walked to my room and the
guy was walking my room in the hotel
said
you know is it the room and the end the
suite at the end i said
who and he said samuel l jackson and i
said
why he said cause he's shooting a movie
out here and i thought
where's the movie supposed to take place
it was like supposed to take place in
chicago he's a cop it's wintertime time
it's
they're trading out winnipeg for chicago
samuel l jackson's one of the biggest
voices of pay your fair share and pay or
taxes
he lives in beverly hills who's the
first guy to hop on a plane and go to
winnipeg and shoot a movie to save a
couple of dollars in taxes and
credits samuel jackson so the group who
talks
the most about doing the right thing and
what's wrong with paying more and blah
blah
the first people to hop on a plane i
drove brian cranston
to the burbank airport from this studio
because he's shooting breaking bad new
mexico
he's a very liberal guy he's all for you
know raise the taxes and blah blah blah
but he's also
i'm also giving him a ride to new mexico
to shoot four or five seasons of
breaking bad
that's that's how people work